repeat offenders they will be banned
completely now on to katy perry and
orlando bloom the couple is waiting a
little while longer
to tie the knot according to
entertainment tonight they've decided to
put their wedding burner for now because
they want to focus on being parents
instead
the couple they had their first baby
together in august little daisy dove
and i think they're going to kind of
just concentrate on that for now john
nothing wrong with that especially
during the pandemic if you want to have
a big
big wedding you have to wait before you
can have everybody get together so you
know press pause a little bit focus on
the kid and
wait until everything's opened back up
again mercedes one thing that we like
here on good day las vegas is spicy food
it looks like someone else is trying to
help us out to fulfill that need we have
oh yes absolutely mickey d's is bringing
back
a fan favorite the spicy chicken nuggets
and the mighty hot sauce you can now
order them starting on
monday but some people online say
they're already back at some mcdonald's
so it might be worth
a little trip to the drive-through if if
spice is what you like spice up your
life a little bit john
just yeah hopefully i need more of the
mcnuggets to do that but
if people wait in line and they ask to
get the spice mcnuggets and they're not
there
just keep doing the circle around until
they finally say they've got it just you
know do that
lying around you'll be they'll take care
of you eventually
definitely happening on monday for sure
but you know maybe there's a secret
handshake or a knock on the door that
you can do to get them
[Music]
the secret word is mercedes martinez
oh don't don't use me no
okay fair enough well have a good
weekend mercedes enjoy the rest of the
program and again you can listen to
mercedes on mix 941 and las vegas
now coming up later today good to see
you mercedes take care of yourself